eric il ya longtemps que je vous attends
dans cette émission pour une interview
psy
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes mythos
dans mon travail
j'essaie de dire ce que je pense mais en
même temps comme je suis romancier
j'utilise la fiction ouais donc je fais
une réponse y entrent je suis un
mensonge qui dit la vérité donc je mange
avec beaucoup de sincérité voilà vous me
dîtes si ça suffit pas vous arbitrez
judith est ce que vous êtes mégalo
maîtresse judith n'est 13 unis est-ce
que vous êtes mais diallo oui
complètement ébloui bâtiment se voit pas
cela soit
maintenant je bosse j'essaie d'être le
plus humble c'est s'est montrée dans la
glace ouais mais c'est comme l'ump en ce
moment il se sert de trame maison du
marin le matin en me réveillant je me
regarde dans la glace je baisse les yeux
je regardais voilà je vous le fais là
non thierry non j'suis pas mégalo
est ce que vous êtes parano pourquoi
vous me posez cette question
est ce que vous êtes schizo
oui parce que j'ai envie de c'est pas
que je me disperse mais je pense qu en
fait j'aimerais bien avoir des homonymes
et et avoir le don d'ubiquité
voila voila mon rêve c'est ça est ce que
vous êtes maso
j'y travaille allez à canal+ est un
début
je
simplement je suis très douillet alors
je sais pas il aurait le courage
vraiment mais c'est agréable d'être maso
je crois enfin les vrais masochiste
sont des gens très paresseux qui sont
attachés on s'occupe 2,6 c'est pas mal
de dos à dos oui oui mais faire mal ah
oui c'est torse à la mairie oui c'est
agréable mais c'est fatigant c'est
l'avantagé pour ça je dis maso c'est
mieux parce qu'on n'a rien à faire le
sadi qui à la fin de la soirée oui c'est
bon quoi voilà exactement il faut bosser
à voici est ce que vous êtes chaude au
seau d'eau alors oui je suis au dos je
suis actif passif et cette réponse va
rester dans les annales
et que vous êtes vibro je ne vois pas de
raison de ne pas avoir recours aux
progrès de la science
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout ce que j'aurais à dire là
dessus
est ce que vous êtes homo mais on a dans
un journal en 20 ans
qualifié de hétéro [ __ ] oui et on va
se qualifier de quoi dans vingt ans ça
la rue vieux travelo
ben non mais je me suis habillé en femme
pour une soirée le bal des débutantes 1
et j'étais superbe avec une robe
emprunté et je ressemblais
à valérie lemercier dans palace oui ça
fera plaisir si tu nous regardes est ce
que vous êtes trio
non je suis 17 au
22 euros mais je vois pas l'intérêt de
se limiter à trois personnes est ce que
vous êtes zoo
je suis en fait pédo zone et cros
scatophile c'est à dire que je t'aime
bien manger de la merde de jeunes chiens
morts
mais
pour me juger qui êtes vous il faudrait
que chacun ses petites habitudes
oui en même temps c'est tellement
service public qu'on veut pas lui jeter
la pierre
original
chez warner
un très bon produit les corrections de
ne rien rater le il a l'habitude abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu